yes Pauline Dan another surprise caller
he's at Los Angeles sports fan of course
and he also has a show called Curb Your
Enthusiasm Larry David's Klein Oh
gentlemen Larry thank you you're so
smart
hi Larry
hey Thank You Larry Larry says you're so
smart now what what are you doing up
Larry what are you doing over this hour
Larry when am I gonna get invited to
Riviera now that Bel Air's closed for
nine months I'm holding your feet to the
fire Larry we appreciate your calling in
and go ahead and say some nice things
about me in the show then that'd be
great and you are just so wonderful you
know that everybody knows that ten years
here's here's what I want to do okay
as soon as as soon as curb is over I
want to I want to join the the little
Dennis I want to be a Dennis I think
would be a fantastic job I envy the
tenets now I can you get by on thirty
seven thousand dollars a year you know
what I think I can't okay I appreciate
that
now I full disclosure I did call you out
yesterday because I was told through a
friend of yours that apparently you have
an airplane episode coming out in Curb
Your Enthusiasm a seat situation with
the bathroom issues Fritzi brought that
up on the show on time
so just a coincidence is this inspired
by real-life events from Fritzie that
you putted it have you have you filmed
and I think believe it's the sixth
episode this year where there's a
bathroom issue where somebody wants to
change seats with you I believe and you
write you refused to have you filmed
that okay all right well that takes you
off the hook for stealing sampling from
from
dan Larry what was it a g5 or a falcon
mm he had this bathroom Larry goes
commercial commercial yes no I
I heard you big cheapskate you went to
Chicago with all those golf guys you
flew Southwest I heard right Larry but
dense
don't you like the common man who's
taken like yeah but Doc Rivers wasn't
happy about that he wanted to charge by
the way how good are you at golf Larry I
saw the episode with the Swan when you
kill the Swan and the swing looks pretty
athletic there it's almost a Bill Murray
I'll just say this I'm not good but I'm
better than out you're right that
doesn't make you good that is not fake
news he's right but you belong to
Riviera I do yeah well don't see it that
way I mean you know like you sounded
like you know hey I'm embarrassed to
belong to Riviera not bel-air without I
never do well it's there
why do then that first tee the whole
course I just can't play now once again
we want to say thank you for calling in
obviously and good luck with this won't
be the final season of curb right I hope
not if I do another season I'm not gonna
wait five years I could tell you that no
okay so then you would just bounce right
into the next season not wait and make
everybody kind of hold their breath okay
well thank you for calling it Eliz or
anything you'd like to add to the
conversation with Larry before you say
goodbye what time are we team by the way
your jets are doing great oh god please
no you want to games what if I can give
you Josh Rosen at UCLA or Sam darn 'old
which one which quarterback to you what
with the Jets I gotta go with the Jew
Thank You Larry ma Thank you very
that's the great Larry Davis I am yeah
and much NACA's the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience